well nearly two years after his death
police in Baton Rouge Louisiana released
body camera footage of the encounter
with police that left Alton sterling
dead and while the officers are cleared
of criminal wrongdoing one has been
fired and the other suspended we want to
warn you the video you may be seeing is
disturbing here's mark Strassmann
the body camera video begins as two
officers approached a convenience store
after receiving a 911 selling CDs and
threatening someone with a gun it shows
one of the officers holding a gun to the
head of Alton sterling put your hands on
the call
sterling repeatedly asks what he's done
wrong the struggle goes on the officer
repeatedly tries to use his taser
moments later one cop screams he's got a
gun
suddenly three gunshots followed by
three more police say that sterling had
reached for the 38 caliber revolver
found in his pocket they can be seen
here taking the gun to a car I never
feel like I will get justice earlier
this week we spoke to quintella McMillan
the mother of Sterling's oldest son what
do think that video is gonna show that
the security camera video I'm hoping
that that video shows us more than what
we just seen from the personal cell
phones I'm hoping that it can actually
show that the right hand yet they still
saying was not visible so if it's not
visible then how can you say he's
reaching for something but federal and
state prosecutors decided against filing
criminal charges in the deadly shooting
the investigation by the Attorney
General was crap a regurgitation of what
the DOJ did newly released toxicology
reports showed sterling tested positive
for cocaine and methamphetamine is there
anything that would make you more at
peace with this I'd be more peace if
they're fired Baton Rouge Police Chief
Murphy Paul announced late Friday the
termination of officer Blaine Salamone
who fired all six shots officer howie
lake was suspended
for three days the police chief's other
message to the community
please stop resisting people here now
have their chance to study the fatal
confrontation in the most complete and
raw view of Alton Sterling's last minute
of life for CBS this morning Saturday
mark Strassmann Baton Rouge Louisiana